two
here we are my friends
the three million dollar
nuclear bunker where we bring you
the leftovers hell yeah baby the only
podcast on the left
that brings the heat
back to the right
culture warfare and we will win
we took some we took some time off
last week because we were we were
building additional units like more
turrets outside we got some spam
damn surface-to-air missiles yeah
exactly some surface-to-air missiles
installed
you know just in case because these
these it's an arms race out there oh
yeah you know we gotta get in on it
we're gonna teddy fresh manufacturing
weapons now
we are yes we were we were working on
our own custom ar-15 with bump stock uh
optional add-on yeah
yeah but you know looks like a plushie
toy for kids to be able to play with
yeah it's actually a collaboration with
hello kitty
so it appeals to all ages hell yeah
yeah but you know the conservatives it's
arms race uh people are walking around
in tanks and bazookas so you know
gotta be ready you did the ar-15 is is
the weapon of li like yesterday what we
need is is rpgs some rocket-propelled
grenades we have those yeah i mean those
aren't great for like straight
you know one-on-one combat no they're
great for home defense though home
defense is great because that way
you know it doesn't go through the wall
and hurt your neighbor it just just
blows up your whole [ __ ] house yeah
everyone in it like if i can't have my
house no one can yeah oh i'm a socialist
or you don't like that i bought a house
that's this is the normal thing to do i
think today's episode is sponsored by
harry's
raycon and expressvpn
thank you thank you
how are you doing hassan it's been a
week how's everything been
i'm doing pretty good uh we went to
vegas last week that's the reason why we
were uh unable to uh record leftovers i
i did twitch rivals and there was like a
physical event
and of course i thought like oh my god
i'm going to cook these fools like these
gamers like oh wait hold on you guys got
to pull up the clip of a song peeking
between his partner's legs oh you have
that oh no that [ __ ] was funny dude i
put extra effort in that okay so that's
my as my best friend will uh he also
streams on twitch and we were
we were partnered up and of course they
like set the game so it was really fun
it was a lot of fun we did like a lot of
cool activities and stuff but they set
the games up in a way where like it was
universal so like everyone can play and
a lot of gamers are like frail they're
you know 100 pounds max right soaking
wet
so
what they did not factor in was if
you're like a big boy like me you know
260 pounds
then
like most of the competitions are you
have a significant disadvantage there's
like a relay race and stuff so like when
you're really heavy it just like makes
it way harder for you to hit like a
certain speed or
when you there was like a big drop off
into like a pool of foam
and when you fall into the pool of foam
if you're a big boy
all of a sudden you're sinking in it's
much harder to get out so these are like
timed competitions i'm like damn i mean
we we got cooked you got slammed huh we
got like well this was almost last well
i don't i don't know how you lost with
techniques like this this this was high
level let's switch over to well
yeah by the way play that charlie kirk
sound bite wait why is it lagging we
that's right um
charlie's right dude we're sucking and
we're the biggest generation yeah
gays hell by the way who who put that on
because like it was obviously a big
twitch dude oh they actually they uh
they hadn't had they had not done any
rivals for uh years obviously it was a
culvert so they were like really excited
to do like a big event yeah they really
went i mean it looked great the sets and
everything yeah it was sick they
they work with like a bunch of
professional people like the guy who
like
was the head of like all the events was
like an american ninja warrior dude you
know what i mean like it was legit like
they had like tv producers and stuff it
was cool you know what's interesting i
weigh almost as much as you isn't that
crazy how much do you wear
last it last i weighed in
like 245 okay
245 was like i would be
really happy to get back down to 242 i'm
260 right now yeah but you're like 10
feet taller than me and like 10 feet
wider yeah i am very dense boy i'm very
wide um not as dense as me apparently
yeah i uh i'm like tungsten
i when i was 230 pounds i had like a
straight six back 230. so that's one
that's pretty light down to
2 30. okay good luck best luck to you
yeah well we got to help you steroids
this is
have you ever done steroids no but i
would like to i'm just why why what's
hot stopping you
um i have a really addictive personality
so i i just worry that i'm gonna turn
into a ninja turtle you know what i mean
also
it to make you like angry and unhinged
that seems bad i'm also like i'm already
an angry dude so i don't need i don't
need any more i don't need any more
testosterone also doesn't it shrink your
your balls and
whatever that's an extra inch on your
dick then you know an inch off your
balls is an inch on your dick i don't
think that's how it works
i don't think it makes it look bigger i
think that's all a nice uh well as your
muscles get bigger your your dicks
definitely look smaller
bro i'm already a big boy it doesn't
matter yeah he's already it's already a
little [ __ ] well i don't know but yeah
the fatter i get the smaller my dick
looks that's for sure yeah
this is thicker
i kept i keep getting bigger but my dick
stays the same size yeah well that's
that's how it works usually
um unless you do hgh a human growth
hormone
that one that one helps out down there
that literally grows everything it grows
really yeah it grows your heart that's a
bad yeah you don't want to grow your
heart but i but i uh suspect that a lot
of like you know allegedly
hollywood actors are probably doing that
yeah yeah you know you just you get like
[ __ ] taller and [ __ ] your body is
actually yeah you get taller your head
grows your [ __ ] everything grows
human growth hormone it's literally what
you have in your body it's like what
causes you to be a certain size that'd
be kind of cool if we all did that for
like a year just to see like see what
happens a podcast experiment but that
should be illegal right
that's what happens oh yeah yeah okay
allegedly okay so you don't think this
was a natty gains because this guy
looked like i mean this guy was like a
tiny nerd before the marvel training
yeah i mean i love that okay shouts out
to show me the before shout out to all
the the brown boys out there [ __ ] oh
yeah look here look two years later
he looks scary bro look at this he's dr
he's gotten out of his truck
his wife beat her doesn't fit him
yeah
the thing that i uh
uh the other reason why i don't want to
do steroids because like i'm worried
that my hairline will [ __ ] evaporate
you don't need to do steroids come on
man you're already jacked i mean i
probably will eventually i'll probably
do like three rt when i well yeah when i
hit like 35 36 and my testosterone level
starts declining i'll probably do a
little bit trt interesting yeah little
joe rogan treatment little joe rogan
they won the nobel prize yeah just a
little bit a little trt side of ivor
mexton you know just in case because you
never know i mean ivor mexton did win a
novel uh nobel prize that's true so yeah
those are the facts it's undeniable well
hold on anything else other than that
hold on um
is it illegal to do steroids you have to
get it on the black market um trt you
can get it like you know approved by a
doctor uh for sure a lot of steroids you
can get approved by
you go to like a uh uh
there's probably like uh physical
therapy doctors or whatever that will
give you that with they're like oh your
testosterone levels seem to be declining
it seems okay
like the doctors on the border that like
oh you definitely need oxycodone yeah
kind of like that
for that uh toe that ingrown toenail
yeah so you know there is like medical
uses for it and they and that's like
probably healthier than just like
[ __ ] doing it off the street you know
what the [ __ ] in it
well you know what whatever you got to
do hassan i don't think you should do it
i want you to be a healthy boy
you're already jacked but you do what
you ever got to do i know that there's
you're like a kind of a you exercise so
much you're so dedicated that so i know
that you guys you guys who are into that
whole world have a different uh
yeah no i love i love i love working out
it's great it's fun it's a it's like
meditation i wish i loved working out
i'm jealous of people like you i mean i
didn't like i wasn't born loving working
out i [ __ ] hated it really it's just
like
it's all a matter of um
pushing yourself
out doing it yeah no like it's literally
it's it's both incredibly hard but also
incredibly simple at the same time it's
literally a matter of of um
structuring your life in a way where
you're just like i'm just gonna do this
like it sucks but i'm gonna do it and
i'm not gonna see any [ __ ] results
for like the first month maybe even the
first two months
but the moment you start seeing those
results you're like oh [ __ ] this is the
greatest feeling of all time like
my my weight loss i used to be 320
pounds really yeah and i went all the
way down to 220 in a matter of basically
like a year and a half
and
b and i always wanted to do two things
when i was younger i wanted to have a
six-pack and i wanted to be able to dunk
and being able to achieve both of those
things
allowed me to be like oh [ __ ] like if i
worked super [ __ ] hard you wanted to
dunk that was one of your motivators
yeah okay and can you dunk to this day
now i can't not right now too i haven't
played yeah i'm too heavy and i haven't
played basketball in like a while i'm
gonna i'm gonna start doing it again
though all right so we've got a bunch of
good stuff to get to
the conservative sphere is losing its
mind as always and there's just so much
to cover dude sometimes
you know over the past week i've just
been losing faith i just i feel like
this country's lost and i i mean this
like and if i really just think we're
talk we're lost to idiocracy the more i
look at uh the more i cover politics
like lately the more i feel sad about it
yeah so you just gotta take your [ __ ]
uh victories wherever you can people
constantly come to me and they're like
there's nothing feels good nothing feels
good climate and i just think we're
losing we're just losing our country to
you know
um
the people who are uneducated who are
buying the propaganda
of people like this are i was just
listening you know to the daily on the
way over
she this woman got a phd and [ __ ]
she is an expert in the field
and she was in a small town in kansas
she would have worked there lived their
whole life serving the public everyone
trusted her everyone loved her when it
come to covet all of a sudden people
started turning on her sending her death
threats that she had to get escorted out
people are accusing her of being a
fascist like this was a this was a good
respectable member of the community that
everyone loved and when it come to her
trying to enforce the the government's
health policies people wanted a [ __ ]
killer the same people
um yeah but that's there's just hordes
of these people
um it's it's deliberate
i mean yeah we know there's empirical
evidence to show and not that the
democrats are like uh all that better
but they are at least better on this
area right when it comes to you know
at least uh
offering lip service to the science
right and admitting the truths the
scientific truths a huge difference no
there's a gigantic difference for sure
um i do still think that the democratic
party's inaction creates this system
where
we have to battle out on like whatever
wedge issues that republicans decide is
like something that we should be angry
at because like if the democratic party
legitimately was like no [ __ ] this like
we're going to give you health care
that's all we're gonna do i'm gonna give
you healthcare no matter what and if
they fought as hard as the republicans
fight for whatever kind of [ __ ]
psychotic new thing that they've created
for themselves if they fought as hard
for that then they could be known as the
party for health care yeah i agree and
then and then you'd be like do you want
health care shut the [ __ ] up and vote
democrat yeah but they claim that they
want it and then they never act out on
those desires because they kind of don't
well like anyway here let's just watch
this every political ad is exactly the
same so here's these these guys trying
to sell themselves as a good old salt of
the amer of the earth americans
it's all conservatives obviously yeah
including joe mansion in the bottom left
there's that
i mean he's a conservative yeah he is
america has some big problems this
motherfucker's holding a pig in his hand
i love that dude i love that that dude
is walking with a piggy come on now here
down here
i can't get over this dude holding a
piggy big dan roddenberry for congress
i'm about to eat this big hole boy yeah
that's [ __ ] awesome that's a cute-ass
pig though dudes pigs are so cute when
they're little babies and they become
like giant monsters
i'm sure you've seen it paid for by
washington special interest
i'm marjorie green and i approve this ad
i'm michelle fiore and i'm running for
governor
i got a big truck wait
wait
oh both i'll vote for him
that boy's got a big old truck big
big brian camp look what it says deport
criminal illegals
i got a big truck and i can fit lots of
illegals in it um
wait this music is the same in every ad
it's insane
yes a twangy country uh slide guitar
yeah that's that's that's what the
that's what the workers of the united
states love okay twangy country guitar
wow
track shots of my pickup truck that i
rented out for the day that i got on a
high tech drone special interest
i'm marjorie green and i approve this ad
i'm michelle fiore and i'm running for
governor
it's actually the same truck
control over our economy
yep i just said that
i'm ready for congress to put an end to
this hogwarts to strip power from the
federal government and that ain't going
to happen i own guns
to defend your rights at politics as
usual
[Music]
socialism
it's time to fight back
[Applause]
yeah so this this is what we're up
against here
no substance just a couple of yee has a
gooey in the arms some guns and some
trucks well like what are they gonna run
on they're not gonna run on like i'm
brian kemp and i wanna i mean he's
running for governor right but like you
know you're not gonna have them run on
like i wanna make sure that we
deregulate the fossil fuel industry so
that uh you know the corporate
executives make
the a ten percent uh
year-over-year profit like i'm entering
congress to ensure that we can never
negotiate the prices of uh
pharmaceutical drugs yeah exactly it's
like that's not gonna play well so you
gotta like shift the attention away it
works we are so [ __ ] bro the pickup
trucks work we have no we have no
institutional like we have no
institutions we have no organizational
tools that is completely withered away
no union power whatsoever absolutely
decimated in this country yeah trump
power so when that happens the people
can't make demands for material change
uh effectively and the people that are
voting
are you know relatively uh in a better
situation overall than the average
american worker or the people that don't
even work
and you know their demands are being met
obviously uh to a certain degree that's
why you got the salt deduction
in the in the build back better [ __ ]
bipartisan legislation what is the salt
deduction salt deduction uh there was a
cap that was introduced to the salt
deduction in the trump air tax cuts that
what does salt mean so it's a state and
local tax deduction right okay and what
happens is like you're allowed
if you're allowed to deduct certain
things from your state and local taxes
if you're making certain expenditures
right
and it's uh and there was a cap that was
introduced in the trump bill because
they wanted to like reorganize the
revenue structure and it's actually only
good for like salt is only good for
people living in high
state taxes wait are you talking about
like the california state income tax
that used to be fully deductible and now
it's max are like
very low number yeah exactly so that's
precisely what it is i pay double tax
now on all my state tax yeah it's
awesome so
trump passed that [ __ ] just to [ __ ] over
blue states
like i feel like
yeah that and also because it was like a
good funding mechanism to like just you
know
to make up for all the other areas where
they were lowering taxes drastically you
know what i mean it was basically a wash
against the new tax deduction that trump
passed
so my taxes stayed about the same but if
both of them were removed i'd be at like
60 probably effective yeah
yeah so you know uh what 20 times more
than elon most effective tax rate
okay shout out king yeah so he did he
did three percent um the truck driving
hog yielding
uh people running for office here's a
little snippet here's marger and taylor
green she was driving a humvee
in her ad but it looks like she's in a
luxury sedan or sedans four-door right
yeah yeah just a nice luxury stand
that's not definitely not a humvee so
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa where's the
humvee
yeah she doesn't drive that and then
you've got the uh the hog toten
wrestler i'm just a good old yihab boy i
grew up i work our cowboy hats no
[ __ ] you grow up in new jersey
shut the [ __ ] up rockaway new jersey and
attended seton hall prep school like
come on [ __ ] up douchebag
hey he played football at usf so then
after that he's like that's right i'm a
southern boy now i'm playing football
give me that hog
yeah
this is dan sullivan
my favorite is like the peter thiel guys
now like jd vance is one of them
and another dude is uh [ __ ] what's that
other guy i think he's in arizona from
shark tank right no
no no no no jd vance is like the guy who
wrote the hillbilly elegy that like
liberals [ __ ] loved because he really
like mystified the white working class
because he's from [ __ ] kentucky and
ohio and [ __ ] so it's like
but he's just like he's a piece of [ __ ]
he went to yale like
josh hawley talking about [ __ ]
masculinity all the time like oh yeah we
need to save men i need to save these
young boys it's like dog you literally
went to stanford and you kiss your wife
like you're grossed out by her and also
you kiss your wife like god's watching
and also on top of that like you got
caught yeah that's what that's how this
beacon of masculinity kisses his wife
dude
and she's cute too goddamn josh holly's
wife hit me up wait hold on
can we get yeah she she she looks like
yeah i hate to say it but quartering
cover your ears she looks like brie
larson here
yeah i mean he he's a good-looking dude
too he's like he works out he's jack you
think so yeah i've seen him i've seen
the photo of him at [ __ ] whole foods
at 3 30 buying wine at whole foods like
oh i'm not 330. yeah he's like i'm a
missouri i'm i'm a real missouri boy i'm
josh hawley like i love missouri and i
love you know i'm going to protect your
rights racism what these guys create
these rigid like masculine uh norms that
they themselves do not abide by of
course
yeah 2 30 on a week oh in the middle of
the [ __ ] day injections dude oh yeah
he's got some pecs boy damn how you got
time to work out like that he's just
such a dildo that like
it's not gonna like the the whole
concept is just like it falls apart he's
just pete buddha judge but for the
republican party you know what i mean
so but any these guys are just
pretending to be like uh you know white
trash but they're not they're actually
just rich city slickers who would do the
same elite universities of people they
say they hate they're literally wolf in
sheep's clothes and they're lying to you
this guy sullivan let's see he graduated
mega [ __ ] laude from [ __ ] harvard my
dudes yeah ted cruz
also harvard dan crenshaw also harvard
harvard is like the
epitome of established [ __ ] coastal
elitism upper exclusive upper
classmanship
yeah it is and also they are hyper
neoliberal so that is from where i'm
standing that's like a very conservative
world view it's not an accident that a
lot of these [ __ ] war criminals come
out of yale and harvard and they have
like a direct talent pool into the cia
um but this one's my favorite brian camp
net worth four million broken brian camp
i have a big old truck
broke boy dude only 4 million that's
true these other guys put him to shame
yeah what a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that's
why he has to like do all the [ __ ]
weird financial [ __ ]
joe manchin of course assault of the
earth good old boy drives a [ __ ]
maserati i saw a video of him being
blocked blocked by climate uh activists
yeah he was driving a maserati what's
like a 300 000 car i mean i know he's
rich but damn i don't think it's
actually that much but still
really
yeah huh
it's still a maserati i mean how much is
it look it up what's it msrp at maserati
their their cars are not exactly known
as super prestige anymore they'll stop
yes they are how much is that car though
oh damn they're right it's like 72 grand
msrp 80 grand what it's not astronomical
oh okay yeah i mean it's still not a
[ __ ] picture no it's not i'm saying
that's that's obviously expensive but i
always thought maseratis were like they
fell off i mean 80 grand for about 80
grand for a luxury suv like yeah i
thought that it was gonna be like 200
grand yeah i thought they fell off
[ __ ] ratio yeah plus you're white
um this [ __ ] who is out here
this guy greg gianforte yeah it made 220
million dollars over 10 years
puts brian kemp to shame
yeah brian camp is a broke boy so is joe
biden by the way that's like one of the
funniest things is like bro you've been
in senate for like 700 years how the
[ __ ] are you like
like i don't know if you know this
but joe biden couldn't pay his son's
medical bills and barack obama had to
like give him money this is like a
famous story and this [ __ ] is
still dedicated to like nuking any sort
of like socialized uh social spending
for healthcare is he really that broke i
guess well i'm usually these guys like
like obama became super rich after
presidency just wrote a book did the
oprah tour or joe biden's net worth went
way up after he was vice president yeah
but oh dead
yeah i mean before that i believe
speaking fees and all that kind of stuff
how's this how much is joe biden worth
as recently
that ain't no poor boy bro are you
kidding me as a as a previous uh vp like
he literally as recently as november
2009 his net worth was less than 30
grand wait when was that
when he like the first year of his vp
his net worth was 30 grand so that's
like the funniest part about joe biden
is that like i mean he's obviously bad
finance right there dude that it's
shocking that joe biden who has worked
who's sided with banks and his sides
with like capital and he's not even he's
not even benefiting from them for
nothing exactly if you're going to at
least at least get the bag i mean yeah
joe manchin's i mean these guys are
worth hundreds of millions like damn
yeah
by the way in other news you guys
probably all heard about what we talked
about on the show
the q anon conspiracy theorists have
basically fringed out they no longer
need a leader they no longer need q
and they all met on uh
on the grassy knoll where jfk was
assassinated
awaiting his son jfk junior who's been
dead 20 years
to that's what you think liberal right
that's what that's what the narrative is
that's sheep wake up ethan yeah
sorry i didn't mean to say he's i'm just
saying that's what the official
narrative is
they know he's alive they've been
waiting
for him to come back
they were all there thousands of people
very disturbing
um
well he didn't come back but the good
news is that they're still holding
there's a big group of them are still
waiting for the return on the grassy
knoll
this is um one week after he failed to
return from the dead they're still
waiting for him
they're still waiting
they're still waiting my friend
this is a cult i don't know what to say
if you're still yeah i mean it's it's
there's a lot of people in this call too
yeah
well they got a lot of guns this is what
happens when you're like i i feel like
things are not great okay people keep
telling me things are great but i feel
like things are not great
and no one is actually actively telling
me why things are not great except for
[ __ ] q anon which is packaging this
in like a very
murder mystery style conspiracy so i'm
gonna follow along
on these forums and uh i'm going to
dedicate my entire life to it like this
is there this is providing purpose for
ultimately a group of you know
i know you could group individuals you
could make that that that
claim for any cult
but the fact that they're willing to
believe people use the problem is
they're these
it's like a cult blown in the wind and
the conservatives use them to
further their agenda that's really
dangerous conservatives are brilliant at
doing that because like they're overall
this is us by the way
we're gonna run for office together and
all of a sudden we're gonna i mean we're
we got more money than [ __ ] brian
camp especially combined we could
destroy him brian kemp yeah well outside
him
easy
put a little subtext here richer than
brian kemp yeah
exactly broadcast [ __ ] loser
yeah but uh we were talking about the
republican party but like they're
they're just so good at like
yeah finding whatever thing
is like motivating the base because
ultimately like their desires are
morally bankrupt i think you're not
going to motivate people by being like
we're going to cut social spending we're
going to social security is not going to
motivate people to turn out the vote i
think the the what what benefits the
republicans is just they actually are
have no scruples they don't give a [ __ ]
they'll say and do anything at any price
for power and that's how you win yeah
and the democratic party's like
basic uh uh
way of trying to win elections is like
is to allow republicans to win so they
can point at them and be like look how
bad they are come on dude you don't want
this to happen again and republicans are
so morally bankrupt they will
go to the next level and do like
horrifying [ __ ] i mean dude just look at
the discourse about critical race theory
i just my eyes are rolling into the back
of my [ __ ] head every time i see
a d and this is like not this is
mainstream [ __ ] this isn't fringe stuff
our kids are learning about critical
race theory and kindergarten a fringe
[ __ ] racial theory that's taught in
like graduate studies for only law
school grads yeah
is being taught to our children
it's not happening it's literally
[ __ ] so dumb
so i just it's it's just it's maddening
i can't yeah beautiful part about that
of course is that
created that line is directly created by
christopher ruffo of the manhattan
institute and it's not like even hidden
he openly
way back in the day like uh you know
when he when he first got on tucker
carlson's broadcast was like yeah we
created critical race theory as a
concept as a talking point so that we
could you know make all of the things
that the democratic party represents
fall under that umbrella and we toxify
the brand of critical race theory which
now everyone gets upset about which is
like not even a thing the people you've
done like i've seen so many videos you
go up to a random conservative out of
protest and say what is critical race
there and they they go i don't like the
good life i don't
yeah i don't know what it is but i don't
like it it's like i don't like it you
could reduce that to almost every
anxiety that conservatives have it's
like what is what's antifa doing i don't
know they're beating people it's like
all right we're gonna we're gonna go to
a quick break just so we can inch up on
that
on that douchebag what was his name the
broke
boy brian kemp yeah brian camp we're
coming for you during this ad break
republicans don't even like him anymore
because they think like he didn't cheat
enough right so you don't even got
republicans protecting you bro we're
coming for you
ad break we'll be right back time to
take a short break
we're men who need razors
that's right i do i need a razor damn it
actually i like using the razor on my
neck
get that nice clean shave you know yeah
i have a beard like that you like to
have that nice smooth neck yeah
smooth neck so people can see my waddle
it's important
i like to get this part here though you
know there's certain parts you need to
hit the razor you know what i use the
razor for the back of my neck huh cause
you got that long hair you can't see but
my back my neck is all hairy so i use
that razor yeah no i feel that i like
doing that yeah yeah i manscaped
with a razor no yeah i was like i'm
wrong i'll say that because we're doing
a razor right
well no you don't have to you don't have
to say you razer blade your genitals
that's psychotic i would not do that
yeah no not right really
that's
yeah don't do that guys i mean if you
want i think people do it though women
do it
yeah but
i mean there's less the more smooth
areas
there's too much like cracks and
movements and i don't know i mean i
think we don't know women
women know they're slick down there
they've got like weird blade skills yeah
anyway have you looked in the mirror
recently
like really looked that beard you grow
out over the last year was a hot new
thing but wait guys it's getting hot
outside it's time to tame that bad boys
and harry's is here to help
if you don't know harry's it's time you
do harry's was created to be different
from other shaving companies harry's
crafts high quality long lasting blades
and durable weight weighty handles
that make a close comfortable shave
quick and dare we say even enjoyable
absolutely i enjoy shaving a lot
i dare i say it yeah i don't dare
and because harry's insists that you
shouldn't have to choose between a great
shave and a fair price they just give
you both you refill blades start as low
as two bucks so that's an easy decision
and you know what's even easier new
harry's customers get their starter set
which includes a five blade razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel with
aloe and a travel cover it's 13 value
for just three bucks
they're loop practically losing money at
that point yeah they're they must be out
of their [ __ ] minds it's crazy
plus harry's offers a whole range of
amazing face and body care products for
men all delivered right to your door
uh
yeah i've used harry's the razor is
awesome you know there's no point to get
it anywhere else honestly with that
crazy that hardy blade those good
you got that weight it's a weighty
handle boy you could [ __ ] knock
someone out there and then shave your
yeah i fight uh my enemies
when they when i'm shaving a man right
there combat shape when i'm shaving and
and you know uh a bunch of uh ninjas
break into my bathroom i could fight him
off with my harry's my weighted hand up
yeah we love it folks there's never been
a better time to try harry's go to
harrys.com leftovers to get their
starter set for just three bucks there's
100 satisfaction guaranteed too so you
got nothing left to lose go to
harrys.com leftovers right now that's
h-a-r-r-y-s dot com slash leftovers
it's never too early to start gift
shopping for the holidays especially
because today you can save big on a gift
they're gonna use every day it's the
raycon wireless earbuds let's go
let's [ __ ] go i hate wired earbuds i
love the wireless it's one of the
greatest innovations yeah well you know
what sucks about most wired earbuds just
yeah they're [ __ ] expensive they're
expensive and you know you know
i was also going to say that like some
of the wireless ones they you can lose
them or it doesn't fit well in your ear
the ear fit can be weird yeah for sure
but raycon addresses both those issues
they first of all got that seamless
bluetooth pairing and a comfort noise
isolating fit you can start listening
right away and keep listening for hours
they got that good ass battery life boy
and the audio quality is amazing
comparable to what you get from other
premium brands except raycon starts at
half the price
and new everyday earbuds come with three
new sound profiles make sure that
whatever you're listening sounds perfect
with that perfect bass you got pure mode
for podcast balance mode for rock and
heavy metal base mode for hip hop
let's go
it's all it's all applicable to this
leftovers podcast
yeah all of them actually it does say
podcast on all of them which is kind of
funny yeah except for bass mode but our
podcasts you can do yeah you can crank
up the bass mode too yeah raycon offers
eight hours of play time
and a 32-hour battery life there's also
a built-in mic so you can take calls on
your earbuds with the press of a button
and this holiday season get them
something they can use for calls or
music or work or play or on the or at
home or on the go you know what it is
pick up a pair for yourself or your
loved one trust me you're gonna use it
every day yeah the other thing i like
about the raycon is that it's
it is super comfortable they have all
the different
um
sizes yeah and it's just like a little
nestled in your ear like a dream
yeah there's there's uh there's some you
know very famous uh brands out there
that fall out of your ear and that's not
good not good and you can't even you
don't even have like a customizable head
to change it nope you know what i'm
talking about you know who are the
dressers i won't won't say the name of
the brand you [ __ ] we're not allowed
to say it and i wouldn't even yeah go to
buy raycon.com leftovers today to unlock
exclusive deals up to 20 off your raikon
order but hurry this offer is available
for a limited time only and you don't
want to miss it that's by raycon.com
leftovers to unlock a 20 off your
raycons by raycon.com
leftovers thank you
i know what most of you are probably
thinking why don't you just use
incognito mode you deprived sick [ __ ]
well let me tell you something incognito
mode does not hide your activity it
doesn't matter what mode you use or how
many times you clear your browser
history they know what you've been doing
they know what you've been up to the
internet provider can still see
everything it's every single website you
visited
yeah degeneres
i don't know want to know what kind of
sick [ __ ] hentai
like
that's why even when i'm at home i never
go online without expressvpn okay don't
throw me under the bus express
i'm not on those weird hentai sites yeah
okay
you said it every single website ethan
yeah
it doesn't matter who your internet
service provider is isps in the us can
legally sell your information to ad
companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connections
through their secure service so your isp
can't see the sites you visit expressvpn
also keeps all your information secure
by encrypting 100 of your data with the
most powerful encryption available and
most of the time i don't even realize i
have expressvp on it runs seamlessly in
the background and it's so easy to use
all you have to do is tap one button and
you're protected expressvpn is available
on all devices phones computers even
your smart tv so there's no excuse for
you to be using it yeah i mean that and
there's so many reasons you you may want
to use a um you can unlock you can
unlock different uh ip you get around
different ip like regional locks yeah
you can i mean i used to say this and
i'm no longer allowed to say it but i
used to tell people to get a vpn i don't
have a con sponsorship with them or
anything but
so that they could avoid seeing the ads
that i have to run oh really yeah
so if they connect from like europe or
canada or something they don't see it
yeah they just like say i'm watching
from somalia oh yeah
that's awesome yeah
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet visit
my exclusive link
expressvpn.com leftovers and you can get
an extra three months free on a one year
package that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com leftovers expressvpn.com
leftovers to learn more
all right we are back here is dennis
prager the greatest well great thinker
on the right this is a serious
individual
yeah he actually even has a
university uh aka youtube channel yeah
propaganda it's the best technically
it's just a you yeah it's like kfc
it's not real chicken
so braids you're used to you're just
pregnant it's not a uni you you're meant
to think that but ben is prager yeah
yeah the og the og granddaddy of uh you
know this kind of rage culture
reactionary politics famous for um
writing not one
but two essays on why you should be able
to do spousal
oh for real yeah can you pull those up
yeah it's uh called when a woman isn't
in the mood no way let's go
dennis now no woman's ever in the mood
looking at this guy when a woman isn't
in the mood part one what part one
my boy yeah once again a reminder this
is not a fringe guy this is a darling of
the right
this is a guy you will see on every
mainstream show
he is considered a great thinker and he
has more in common with isis apparently
than uh oh yeah then uh a average
american one hundred percent
um what the hell [ __ ] chicago about how
like you know you can call them the show
and be like dennis i listened to your i
listened to your advice and now i'm
going to jail my wife wasn't in the mood
okay wait when first told this about men
women generally
you got to pull out some good nuggies in
here okay a woman wait go up go up
first women need to recognize how a man
understands a wife's refusal to have sex
with him a husband knows that his wife
loves him first and foremost by her
okay dude just by her willingness to
give her body to oh wow i stopped her a
husband knows that his wife loves him
first and foremost by her willingness to
give her body to him dude you have sick
you're sick in the head bro yeah that's
how you know it's like
it's not about like mutual respect and a
partnership give her but also not even
like having it's about submission yeah
it's submission in every step it's it's
not like you know the union of uh like
two people having sex together no it's
giving your body to him to be a [ __ ] toy
yeah whatever he wants that's why he's
had seven divorces i i joke about this
double back up i want to finish that i
do this a lot but like this is rarely
the case for women few women know their
husbands love them because he gives her
his body
that is therefore usually a revelation
to women many women think men's natures
are similar to theirs yeah well this is
like 2008 uh he is he's i don't know
which divorce he was going through at
this point but
um you know it
i like to learn about how to treat my
wife from dennis prager like i i want to
go to his you know html [ __ ] website
in 2008 to learn more about
how to treat my wife yeah i like to do i
like to get my that's like getting your
human resource uh human resources
training from jeffrey dahmer yeah
how to treat uh how to interact with
other humans in a way a sustainable way
wow seven divorces so yeah anyway we're
leading
quite a lead up to this guy because he
really is a piece of [ __ ] i mean he
really is
uh consistently the worst
so here he is talking about how
people who are unvaccinated are peris of
society with one interesting comparison
but somebody in her party has a magic
wand the reason we're paying so much is
because the magic wand of the democratic
president
was to destroy the
the energy independence of the united
states of america
with one magic wand the man ruined our
economy
ruined the ability of the of the lower
and middle class to pay their energy
bills
as in germany by the way
this is not just unique to the united
states
anywhere that you have people who are
governed by fear of global warming uh a
idiotic
irrational
sick fear
of some extinction of the of the
the global warming uh global climate
change denial just a little bonus um
i wonder why dennis prager has such a
such a profound view on global warming
that completely contradicts of course
scientific consensus for many many years
that has only increased actually went
from like 97 to like 99.9 at this point
perhaps it has something to do with his
who funds prageru depends on donations
to produce its content much of prageru's
early funding came from hydraulic
fracturing
uh billionaires dan and ferris wilkes
that's awesome yeah
um you want to know more about ferris
wilkes who is also a pastor of the
assembly of yahweh seventh-day church
near yahweh
yeah a conservative messianic israelite
church that was founded by his parents
in 1947 the church takes a literal
approach of the bible that's when you
know shit's popping like when you take a
literal approach of the [ __ ] bible uh
considering it historically and
scientifically accurate
okay so much so that in fact they think
homosexuality and abortion including in
cases of rape and incest should be
convictable crimes well that's not that
different than what's going on in texas
like on a white scale but what's
interesting about a scientific i mean
what's really interesting about looking
at the bible from a purely factional
interpretation is that i see people you
know ripping off their ribs and spawning
women from them regularly yeah that
happens frequently that's how i created
ela that's why we have such a good
relationship
uh here so here he's getting to the
point here okay let's get to the big
vaccinated who who are back a little bit
whether whether it is of of the
non-vaccinated
who who are
the pariahs of america as i have not
seen in my lifetime any pariah group
like like this during the aids crisis
can you imagine if if gay men and
intravenous drug users who
were the vast majority of people with
aids had they been
a pariahs the way the
non-vaccinated are can you imagine that
can you imagine saying that that would
be so crazy if that could happen it's
like [ __ ] you're not you're not
17 years old you were alive and a
prominent conservative voice back then
so i looked it up i was like there's
gotta be some [ __ ] that he absolutely
[ __ ] said yeah and i thought to
myself like i wonder what dennis prager
had to say in the 80s right about uh you
know gay men and the oh you got some
good [ __ ] yeah no way he aids uh uh you
know the aids crisis considering that he
did that
i just want to read one quote from him
from uh just guess what time period it
comes from the great majority of
american indians understandably just
don't care like heterosexual aids and so
many other crises this has been entirely
manufactured by the left dennis prager
does not believe
that aids
can be contracted by uh by heterosexual
people
so almost make he is in a way you could
say treating gays during the aids uh
during endemic like
during in the in the nineteen years but
no this was in 2014 then
he's like
he's like
yeah it would be crazy if people were
treating gay men like pariah is there by
the way [ __ ] during that
crisis gay men were like extremely
[ __ ] uh
targeted by hate they were not taken
seriously they were not treated people
wouldn't even touch them do you
understand people treat him like they
had leprosy i mean for him to even make
that comparison and and and sit in a
serious way is [ __ ] disturbing me
in 1985 the vast majority of americans
said it was probably true that most
people with aids were homosexual men and
more importantly than that among
americans who reported knowing a gay
person
in the 80s
more than one in five 21 percent said
they had become less comfortable around
that person since learning about aids
so this notion that like gay people were
not treated as pariahs during the
[ __ ] aids pandemic epidemic is silly
it's psychotic it's so well documented
that was just a horrible horrible time
to be
a gay person and
with or without aids you know what i'm
saying yeah and uh for him to compare
unvacs guess what dennis i can get from
kovid i can get it from standing next to
your dumb fat [ __ ] unvaccinated
greasy he didn't own kova though he's
not dead unfortunately right he did he
got
joe rogan hooked him up yeah in two
separate polls in 1987 roughly half of
americans agreed that it was people's
own fault if they got aids and that most
people with aids had only themselves to
blame between 43 and 44 of americans in
1987 and 88 believe that aids might be
god's punishment for immoral sexual
behavior not prize
how can you be a pariah if you brought
it on yourself yeah exactly
yeah i mean what a [ __ ] psychotic
freak that is still like a raging
homophobic
freak and also just so desperate to be
the victim
of not being vaccinated
yeah weird they love conservatives love
looking for you know victimhood
narratives and this is a mainstream guy
i mean i have to really emphasize this
this is a prominent well-respected
figure on the right who is openly
homophobic
who is openly anti-science
um wants to say the word
he is open to raping your spouse
apparently which you didn't know yeah
oh yeah sure pull up the n-word one
because that was pretty good too yeah
just
needs to say it he's like why can't i
say the n-word i mean these are these
are important uh cultural flash points
for the conservative movement so it's
not a surprise that dennis prager is a
champion for all of these causes
you know
being able to say the n-word is a
profoundly important part of uh the
conservative free speech debate
700 000 people have died of aids uh hiv
in the u.s
since the beginning of the pandemic
more people have died of covid now yes
maybe
yeah yeah i just saw that stat and was
that's kind of that's eye widening and
the seriousness of the current crisis
that we're in because i think everybody
understands how serious aids is more
people have died of coven
in such a shorter period of time yeah in
just a few years
you have that one of him being like why
can't i say the n word i'm looking for
it right now yeah love him dennis prager
ladies and gentlemen
while we're waiting on that charlie kirk
another great thinker to the right
small face big brain that's what they
say is it a surprise that like all of
these [ __ ] uh
sexless weirdos are uh you know
all funded by billionaires and would not
be able to launch a project if it were
uh grassroots funded in any meaningful
capacity yeah it's awesome propaganda by
the billionaires i mean they're getting
their money's worth easy
it's not really a great market not not
not necessarily look at the whole
country there charlie kirk they're
definitely not with dennis prager they
might be giving it's not giving them
that much him a [ __ ] they give him a lot
of money but he bills himself as like a
guy who is the understander of the youth
which will make this uh conversation all
the more funny but in
charlie kirk is just in terms of the
it's not tragic it's having on culture
though it's it is profound well charlie
kirk is not changing the youth's mind
though that's what i was trying to say
he's just he makes it seem like he is
but if you look at this like facebook
ads for turning point usa they're all
targeting like
75 plus yeah you know now here's a young
man that gets it yeah exactly here's
dennis what year is this from dan
uh
last year
last year let's go
yeah jews and blacks in the united
states i was talking about private
anti-semitic and anti-black language
used by presidents truman and nixon yeah
when was that yes yes that's that's
correct my mistake excuse me um but you
mentioned that president truman
used to use the n-word all the time
and then two seconds later you followed
it up with the word type
so why didn't i say why didn't you say
like the k word because uh because the
left has made it impossible to say the n
word
that's disgusting it's a false it's the
only word that you can't say in the
english language
that's disgusting
that he said it's disgusting
you can say it dennis say it go for it
yeah nobody nobody has a device no the
the left has made it impossible go ahead
keep playing it then go ahead say it
dennis say the k word because the left
doesn't give a damn about that word
i don't want you because that that's why
this is not even the left runs the
country in the culture can't say that
either the also isn't dennis prager
jewish yeah
so he's i [ __ ] hate these guys he's
got the k word pass yeah he gets the
k-pop that's the that's the irony is
that like he should just yeah yeah
yeah
i'm jewish
you know
it's true
it's a nasty word though yeah go ahead
then
yeah the republicans have the senate and
the presidency and that's very important
but we still don't have the end pass and
the more the left controls the more
totalitarian it is that is not an attack
it's a statement of fact like two plus
two equals four yeah
it's idiotic that you cannot say the n
word idiotic
of course you should never call anybody
the n word that's despicable
it's just you can't even say that the
word is despicable
you have to say the n word
you have to say it say it dennis that's
the answer say it
say it dennis you know you know after
the show's over he's saying it
he's screaming it he just has to get it
out of his system but he's saying i love
that he goes the fact that we can't say
the n word is going to be the end of
society we as we know it's all falling
apart around us the radical left has
stopped me from saying the n word which
i love to say and should be able to say
i just can't say it say it dennis you
can say it
it perfectly shows that the entire
argument is built around this like you
know [ __ ] uh reason the free speech
argument in and of itself is like all
about just being able to say hate speech
you can say it without consequences
exactly say that word dennis you're on
your own network nobody's stopping you
yeah come on baby let's do it
yeah i i shouldn't say it i'm going to
say something i don't i i probably
shouldn't say oh joe oh no now
joe has said it before when quoting uh
something joe said like
some white people don't say the more but
they say everything but the n-word yeah
you know what i mean yeah and joe has
definitely done that like yeah have you
ever listened to him defend his crime
bill which was horrifying for the uh
black community in this country that you
know supercharged the racist criminal
justice system paired up with the war on
drugs which joe joe biden also was a big
advocate for
um
there's that famous video of him on the
senate floor describing like why we need
the crime bill and he's just like these
super predators they're going to come
jack and they're going to they're going
to rape your wife they're going to
mallet on your son and your daughters
like that's why we need to
put him in jail
forever like
and it's like dude
at that point you might as well say the
n word you know what i mean like you're
you're literally saying everything but
no no i probably best i don't damn
we got joe in the studio many of you
don't know this but we have him in the
studio we brought his hyperbaric chamber
here
he's pumped he has a huge budget we're
being funded by uh
actually secretly we were being funded
by fracking trillionaires uh from from
saudi arabia to bring take down the u.s
government speaking of well i mean saudi
arabia they don't need frack they're
they're upset new intercept reported a
new intercept report by uh my good
friend ken
shows that mbs is very upset at joe
biden oh no yeah and that's why they're
like uh i guess we have to do everything
to keep mbs happy of course such a good
guy which by the way we're like still
selling him like
garillions of dollars with a weapon so
they can continue the genocide in yemen
but
we're we're also you know wagging the
finger at them and going hey no you're
you're doing bad stuff in yemen don't
don't do that you remember when mbs did
this whole press tour when he ascended
to power about what a great [ __ ]
horse he did like a 60 minutes sometimes
60 minutes really [ __ ] up like i like
that show but sometimes they just miss
the point so hard you know they they
operate as a
uh you know propaganda arm for the state
department and that's precisely what
they did the atlantic like all of these
like supposedly liberal institutions so
hard on the mbs story yeah
and then like one month later he
literally killed
uh
a a reporter what's his name jose uh
kashuk yeah jeremiah
in the turkey they literally murdered
him with a [ __ ] saw axe and left the
embassy in his clothes
psycho
yeah only because he he moderately
criticized the government and and joe
biden moderately criticized
mbs for that because he's like the wolf
guy right well well yeah i mean our
critics get drone strike so that's true
that is guess what
so now he's like uh they're like
manufacturing a shortage as this
suspicion
um which like the american state
department is considering to be kind of
like uh like a tara for almost where
that's part of the reason why the gas
prices are so high oh but they always do
that yeah yeah they're watching their
power you know in the middle east in
israel the gas prices because you know
there's they don't like israel
i think they have to secure different uh
ways of getting oil or
but the prices of oil are so [ __ ]
expensive there and a lot of other parts
of the world probably also taxed out
that i think so but for example it's
four times as much
four times because like in turkey and in
many other countries in europe like oil
is i mean gas is very expensive super
america is one of the countries where
gas is actually people don't realize
like five dollars people are losing
their mind in israel it's like 20 a
gallon i'm not [ __ ] kidding yeah yeah
for sure yeah yeah it's it's absolutely
it's absolutely incredibly expensive
it's basically free here by comparison
yeah especially if you're in like texas
or something that's right baby oh yeah
and in the middle of the country where
they're complaining it's like still 250
you know in california it's taxed to
hell but the problem is like well we i
mean i voted for the ballot provision to
make it higher like because that would
yeah
infrastructure spending me too you know
i'm in favor of it i'm just saying
people outside of america don't realize
how cheap it is yeah but uh
the thing is like
that also impacts other parts of the
economy that impacts everything
obviously that's part of the reason why
like everything
is so cheap consumer goods commodities
for the most part
are is so cheap in america because like
gas is what powers everything right
uh you know the the the travel
accommodations the logistics the supply
chain in its entirety is dependent on
oil and when gas prices are cheap then
goods are cheaper but when it's more
expensive everything becomes more
expensive there you therefore you have
inflation
uh which people [ __ ] freak out over
yeah
well the good news is you know there was
a slight slight drop yesterday in the
stock market but the good news is for
you hassan i was waiting for you to be
here today
that we're back in the green baby up uh
a fifth of a percent today surprised
that the american stock market the stock
market stocks go up stocks are always
are you praying for a
stock market crash no no because
i've seen what happens in the recovery
efforts like it's not like uh a stock
market collapse is good for the working
class it's just still bad because the
losses are socialized and the gains are
privatized so
um for the most part when it when it
falls apart as it inevitably does
because the system is is insane like the
design is insane
um
you have [ __ ] like tesla massively
overvalued
um
do you think a crash is coming
i think i mean crashes are inevitable
right no matter what happens baked into
the system
yeah because the gains lately and the
like apparently were having all these
financial issues but the gains the stock
market has been it uh nauseatingly uh
trending upwards just nauseating since
the pandemic yeah there was that one
crash for like a day
yeah and then they printed like seven
trillion dollars yeah and immediately it
picked back up
it's just it's been nauseating i mean
honestly to be fair like uh donald trump
or rather the american government did
take a lot of initiative in recovery
efforts with
both um
like directly funding the airline
industry
uh in a way where
in a way where like that did
uh that did keep them afloat
and and
most of these industries did not suffer
like gigantic losses
uh during coven because we printed money
and we directly handed it to
corporations
so
um that was
uh at the end that wasn't like the worst
thing and also obviously we experienced
some of the lowest uh some of the lowest
poverty numbers ever
in the beginning of covet because of
direct cash infusions of the working
class too right so you know
redistributive policies they [ __ ]
work
it does uh it just depends on who's
getting the money
interesting yeah
um
but well anyway let's watch uh charlie
this is the generator i was i was
literally thinking like how do we segue
this to charlie
let's just do it this entire time the
country
being an american 15 of millennials say
they are proud to be an american 15
percent
say they are proud to be so mad wait can
you pause the video why is hat fit so i
was just about to say that dude like a
giant dome he's like he's just like
this is a person who's never worn a hat
before
he's the person and he's the person in
the ad in the truck right now yeah i'm
gonna wear a hat with american flag so
they know i'm on their side but it's
like it's like what the [ __ ] like what
it just like looks so uncomfortable on
your head what is happening
how do you fail to wear a [ __ ] hat
dog
well you could tell he's never worn this
before yeah he's got a big noggin dude
he's got a monster potato head yeah
he's one of the strangest looking dudes
i've ever seen in my life oh really like
i don't think i've ever seen anyone else
that looks like him the the last buckle
on that on that bad boy is just holding
on for dear life you know
looking like michelle fiori's [ __ ]
gun holster
about to [ __ ] pop out and like take
someone's eye out you know what i mean
big big boy big head
the country
being an american fifteen percent of
millennials say they are proud to be an
american fifteen percent so angry why
say they are proud to be an american
as i mentioned one-third of millennials
describe themselves as being lgbtq 39
there's more people being gay than being
proud of american yeah those are those
are of course you know separate we need
less gays more pride yeah
americans are more proud of being gay
than they are of being american it's
like make that make sense don't worry
the barb's army
the barb's army's got you covered they
got they're both gay and also proud to
be american now
so
you're fine
39
it's three times
the proportion identified among the
combined older adults in a generation
this is the gayest generation in
american history
and that's not a slur by the way it's
not a slanderer it's just the way it is
i love this part because he's like oh
that's that's a pejorative he look look
look how happy generation american
history it's what the study says he's
like a kid dude he's like this is the
gay generation he's in his 20s he's like
a child well no he's he's my age he's
like i think he's like 28 or something
or 29 uh but
28.
he's 28 yep oh okay
he's like so happy he's like who's the
gayest generation you can't get mad at
me you know you can't get mad at me i
just mean like literally not a
pejorative i just love how it compares
it to pride uh yeah uh being proud of
the uh
of being an american versus being gay
yeah i wonder i wonder why uh just uh
you know more people in the younger
generation are open about their
sexuality than you know prior well here
let me show you an interesting study
this is a history of left-handedness
back in the 1900s
if you were left-handed there was a
movement to force you to go right-handed
you were not allowed to be openly
left-handed openly left hand you
couldn't you had to close with that [ __ ]
and then suddenly you're jerking off
with your left hand like cut that [ __ ]
out
you better not be jerking off in there
with your left no left yeah
don't make me take out the belt so
you know around the 1920s
they said you know what it's okay to be
left-handed you gotta love how [ __ ] up
our world is we're like you gotta
segment everybody left hand these are
are satanists
but i'm sure there was like a like a
commodity production element to it
because like everything is geared
towards all the right-handed people so
they were just like trying to left handy
scissors and [ __ ]
yeah but anyway so they said okay you
know what it's okay to be lefty
left and proud
and then all of a sudden we have the
most left-handed people this is the most
left-handed generation in american
history that's crazy in 1960. this is
wrongest generation in america there's
more people left-handed than there are
proud being proud of america we need to
stop the [ __ ] immediately we need to go
back to the 1900s
yeah so obviously the conclusion is
pretty obvious here it's about not
people actually not being afraid to come
out as gay or trans or lgbt or bi or
whatever yeah uh whatever it is uh
because you know but let's say back here
people uh well prob well people might
kill you
for being gay yeah
or trans especially trans forget about
it
left power yeah shout out uh i was about
to say
ned flanders literally is
single-handedly the reason for why it
happened coincidence and there's
coincidence i think now no absolutely
insiders insider's leftist hero yeah
he was jacked and had a fat hog too did
he have a fat hog
it's implied several times yeah is it
really yeah i know i remember him being
jacked he pipes
that's awesome he's a man of christ what
do you expect exactly
um bless them
sovereign this is a great video let's
just let it run
you know what let's take the let it run
challenge actually no this one's long
this one's four minutes there's no
there's five minutes there's no shot
over here you probably want to skip to
the end after the uh encounter in the
store
i'll tell you when
wait i want to watch this whole thing
bro
it's that good how much time we got
i mean we have time
it's like four minutes long
i'll try to minimize positives
let me set it up for you guys i already
paused it
these are sovereign possible
difficulties
sovereign citizen anti-masters
trespass into a private business
attack the business owner steal her
stuff and then call the cops and then
get arrested
by the cops so
i guess they're coming in her shop to
prove that we don't need to wear masks
they're filming from the onset which i
think means they know they're being
provocative they probably have a history
with this woman
oh yeah don't you offer your services to
the public yes but the safe requires
that you need to be masked in order to
come anywhere inside you can't
you can't deny public services for
federal laws
don't matter 18 you can you can't deny
public service i need my cookies and
crohn's i don't know what that is but
that's it's a federal law you're a
public accommodation you just said
you're open to the public
you
[Music]
i don't want to sell gay cakes i don't
want to sell gay couple cakes but you
got to sell meat cakes even though it's
during a pandemic and i'm not wearing a
mask it's like they got they got the
pamphlets ready too there's ugly ass
pamphlets on the right corner you can
see it you are now frustrated that's not
that's all right
don't touch me don't
[Applause]
yeah the lady was being super fine
the lady pusher oh we got the bat oh
that's awesome
get out hit him right now hit him in the
face get the [ __ ] out
get up
that's why you need a gun they take the
bat
oh they took the bath from her yeah
because the guy stepped in and she never
had a chance
i don't know what these people these
people are just like grown up bullies
psycho freak
oh he's still filming he got the bat and
he's filming it so there is a
scuffle ensues the dog fights
wow he just he's just like all right i'm
out
why do they think filming this was good
well wait they please show up and they
show them the video and get arrested for
it oh [ __ ] yeah that's awesome that's
glorious
[Music]
dude this is her husband just casually
watching this
what a champ what a [ __ ] champion
you don't get to [ __ ] assault people
and run a business
dude you just watched your wife get it
yeah we'll be calling the cops on you
don't worry
yeah so they're gonna these [ __ ]
dumbasses dude they're so entitled with
pause you have positives
i'm gonna die if i don't pause this
video go ahead okay
first of all this is the exact same kind
of entitlement that these [ __ ]
had on january 6 when they were like
yeah i'm here in the capitol [ __ ] you
and like that's precisely why like they
do not live in the real world where they
think like i'm a red-blooded
conservative american and i can go into
the [ __ ] cookie store and like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and then the cops will side with
me of course because i'm a red-blooded
american it's my goddamn right and it's
like no the [ __ ] it's not [ __ ] you
can't do it again there was a whole
culture war you guys may remember years
ago about
a gay couple wanted a cake and the baker
refused to make it for the couple so
it's like
and they were like
the baker has a right to refuse service
to anyone they want and then on the
other hand it's like you gotta let me in
because i don't it's like you can't
they're on both sides of the argument
there's no consistency
yeah at all of course not yeah i have a
right to come into your business and
beat you up
and film you get your ass keep your
weapon after you assault someone with it
you assault his own oh hear the police
surprises they're wearing masks
yeah i know dude look at how much of a
hog the one on the right is i mean
that's a lady hog too but god damn dude
yeah most surprised by big fatty cops
with peace and love like nothing against
fat people obviously i'm one of them but
i don't think cops should be fat dude
like it's a it's a physically demanding
job
you're literally advocating to abolish
the police with that rhetoric but how
can you have a fat cop it doesn't make
sense like firefighters aren't fat ever
those guys are fake well there's some
volunteer firefighters
can be kind of fat i'm just saying there
needs to be a quota we need to
abolish fat cops
don't don't
you sound like a doctor right now
this is like the same kind of this is
the same energy that like doctors have
health care professionals have but um
but for real how do you how can you be a
good cop and be fat you can't [ __ ]
you can't do your job because their job
does not revolve around they just get
out there that's the point their job
literally does not revolve around doing
anything they make it seem like they're
chasing down criminals and
no
no stop absolutely not well when's the
last time you saw a foot chase those
cops do not fare well they feed foot
chases my friend yeah no of course not
uh it's just like
this is what this is what it is for the
most part this is the most action that
they're gonna get other than that they
got quotas they get to write tickets and
[ __ ] you know what i mean and that's it
barely you just get out of your car
that's why so many of the on the job
like on the line fatalities revolve
around heart disease and oh yeah and
getting a heart attack as you like tried
to exert yourself for the first time in
your goddamn life and you're like i'm
dying boom yeah they charged the guy
running with murder yeah thin blue line
not so thin
that blue line it actually well it
depends what you're talking about you're
talking about the artery or they're
physical
because the arteries are getting very
thin
but there's like it's just there is
there literally is a like archetypical
cop
body type like it's just i can spot a
cop from a mile away
even if they're not in their gear i'm
like that's a cop interesting
so anyway here this is a good so let me
go back a little bit so you can see so
the people who went in her shop and
assaulted her showed the cops the video
they're the ones that showed the cops
the video that's like delusional you are
literally psychotic if you think that
like that makes you look good but they
are psychotic
it's the same kind of insanity that
caused them to go into a cookie shop and
be like i'm gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
that is also causing them to believe
that they are in the right here already
interviewed you guys would you mind if i
talk to you separately
you hang out with him
never a good sign sure yeah never when
when when you're when you're being
detained or when you're being stopped by
a cop and they say we need to separate
you that means they're going to try to
find conflicting uh testimony because
you are now under the suspicion of
committing a crime
uh yeah right g rapidly we actually got
it so tell me what your guys's goals
[Music]
we heard a reputation about them oh
reputation and that they've assaulted
other people so that what that means is
they have a reputation is that there's
basically a facebook group dedicating to
harassing small business owners that
actually want people to wear a mask in
their shop psychos absolute psychos i i
hope they go to jail uh i'm not
pretty sure they do see if we could get
a coffee and
before we even could tell her that we
wanted to buy anything she was already
done before before we could even tell
her that we wanted to buy anything she
was already
coming at us trying to remove us you
literally showed her the video you took
that proves that that happened
i don't know why they were arresting her
exactly when she was
attacked yes
yes i was just about to say is there a
moment of realization oh yeah oh okay
let me go back so they separate them
arrested i think she's separating
because she wanted to start arresting
him
this is one of the rare instances where
you see the justice happen in the same
video
they showed the video to the police
they're being it's just it's like it's
wow
that feels good
just hang on
she didn't want her to see
i just wanted to get the rest of your
story
i don't know why they're arresting her
exactly when she was the one that was
attacked
guess who's going to jail tonight [ __ ]
you get a coffee and you didn't really
get a chance she's like don't look there
don't look there
right we raised constitutional and
statutory grounds for our defense to be
there constitutional and statutory
[ __ ] up [ __ ] uh she brought out the bat
and started pushing pushing and shoving
amy in the stomach with it
and amy defended herself and she started
trying to swing the bat so i
if they had not shown the video they
could have gotten away with this oh yeah
if they had not shown the video if they
not filmed the entire process and shown
the video they probably would have
gotten away with it
likely
pretty amazing i just i love that dude
these are well these guys have every
reason to believe the cops are the
allies and they probably have been up
until this point yeah because they've
just been harassing black people before
this yeah and not small business owners
but
um the thing is
one of the one of the elements of this
is that uh there's a lot of like
libertarian guys that do stuff like this
right
and
one thing that i always love is that
like they so if you're a libertarian
you're like supposed to be like oh i
don't like the nanny state
they are the most like
annoying rule breakers that know all of
the rules but have like this distorted
perspective on like the rules only
applying to whoever the [ __ ] they're
like combating in the marketplace of
ideas they just want to like
it's just so [ __ ] annoying it's like
nuclear cringe i just i want you to go
to jail just for that reason alone
you're just like stop well let's see
here his girl got arrested i know this
isn't the outcome that you guys want to
trigger
well this is definitely an unlawful
outcome which is furthering your
unlawful racketeering activity but you
know you guys can just keep doing what
you want
so here's where we're at uh ricky you're
also under arrest okay
so yeah i don't want to
you know
that is illegal
not under the top not for a sovereign
citizen yeah i'm a sovereign citizen
yeah so from so the whole journey of
this video is uh
a fantastic one and i saw in a follow-up
that uh they were charged with both
assault and burglary because he took the
baseball bat oh that's awesome yeah
that's so good i love that they stole
the baby like they could have literally
gotten away with it too it's just like
that it's so perfect that rarely ever
happens no it's a it's a perfect video
yeah wow congratulations shout out to
the sovereign citizens
for this excellent scoop here today
we love our sovereign citizens don't we
folks it straight up stems from their
their entitlement like they just do not
live in a world where they're like
anything i just did here is wrong like
of course i'm going to show the cop a
video of me assaulting a [ __ ] small
business owner because she
did something that was like law abiding
actually
what do you think about terry crews the
scab
oh my wait are there union is there
unionization stuff going on in amazon or
no uh in bessemer alabama in the
distribution facility there was a big
unionization effort which amazon
squashed very successfully
well there's been a lot of uh
propaganda of them trying to get their
their
reputation back because there's been a
lot of stories about people [ __ ] in
bags unsafe work environments not having
time to pee they have little they have
the arm the amazon warehouse workers
have to wear bracelets they get them
back to work so they don't take long
breaks yeah time off task is a huge
point of contention yeah yeah hell yes
they're human robots essentially yeah
they want humans to be robots
and they will replace you soon as they
can by the way
yeah but terry crews got paid to
basically
this is just basically propaganda i mean
100
he he role plays as a working class uh
warehouse worker yeah
did we have a a a title for this one or
no that's the go sorry no yeah yeah okay
love ghost sorry by the way anyway let's
watch this no pause challenge okay 30
seconds
i heard amazon was hiring a billion
people and thought i'd take a look for
myself do you have to go with the arrow
up the arrow up so amazon does pay for
tuition yep
so what do you think my major should be
[Applause]
hi savannah
tuition and flexible hours they're
hiring everywhere so check it out for
yourself
we're here
so here is a
man
who has sold his soul
to bezos what's going on
what's happening does he have like big
gambling debt or something
i don't know
he's always been a bootstrap kind of guy
like people used to love him and then he
came out on some weird uh maggot [ __ ] oh
yeah no he was like a all lives matter
guy exactly that's what it was yeah he
was all lives matter guy he's like big
on anti-porn he said he had a porn
addiction so he's like super anti-sex
work so maybe some of my
dissenters are going to be like oh yeah
good guy terry crews well no
it's interesting the evolution of terry
crews there was a cruise crew subreddit
where there's people like i love him
he's a great guy and then all of a
sudden i think it was the all lives
matter [ __ ] people like ooh this guy's
maybe not that good yeah
he he uh
he suggested that black lives matter
could morph into black lives better
yeah love that great take bro yeah um
you know but uh
he he cared about the optics of that but
uh turns out he does not care about the
optics of [ __ ] you know doing an ad
for amazon like
um so the thing is
amazon starbucks does this too they're
currently actively uh fighting against
unionization efforts in buffalo by the
way
shouts out to the starbucks union uh
unionization efforts in buffalo by the
way i couldn't even really make this
look fun i'm sorry to interrupt you but
i'm looking at he tried to make it look
funny it's really bro you try to make
look like a forklift i mean that's
supposed to be a fun anyway sorry go
ahead so
the thing is
these are notoriously horrible workplace
conditions they don't obviously show
that they're like strapped up to a
machine that [ __ ] literally shows
them with time off task every single
person that's in that video is
technically time off task right now okay
they are not on task they are not
working um thank you so much so they're
they're you know they're you need to get
forklift certified so they're not
letting you [ __ ] drive that thing
without the certification or if they are
then you're gonna injure someone by the
way this is pure fantasy a break yeah
right dude yeah exactly
um i love that the little ways in which
they also uh show like liberal
inclusivity measures like that person is
in a wheelchair like they're doing that
on purpose obviously to be like yeah we
are inclusive like you know we're
it's like yeah they're they're not
okay
like
i don't know what the uh what the
situation is in certain amazon
facilities but i do know
that um
like amazon famously would rather i
believe this was in the uk would rather
place ambulances outside of their
distribution facilities hell yeah
instead of [ __ ] pay for ac
because they were like yeah people are
going to get heat exhaustion and they're
going to go to awesome let's and oh we
got you queued up guys don't worry if
you faint from heat stroke and
exhaustion we have ambulances outside
waiting so keep up that productivity
exactly well actually straight evil like
insanely evil [ __ ] so it's it's super
weird that a guy whose net worth is like
25 million dollars is like yeah i need
to get this amazon ad money like what
are you doing well actually we have um
that that video is actually highly
edited
oh no this is the unedited version no
way yeah here it is you guys made this
that's awesome no this is the um we
discovered it all right 30 seconds no
pause let's just enjoy this
our amazon was hiring a billion people
and thought i'd take a look for myself
do you have to go with the arrow up the
arrow up so amazon does pay for tuition
yep
so what do you think my major should be
benefits tuition and flexible hours
they're hiring everywhere so check it
out for yourself
there you go guys let's get in line baby
yeah
we have and and best of all we've got
ambulances waiting outside yeah oh you
guys will pay for my college tuition if
i like do you think my major if i'm not
clapped up in the insane uh uh overturn
that they have for for employees yeah
don't they they the the average
um
if i make it through like one year on
average well that's that's deliberate as
well yeah
they if you stay in the distribution
facility for long enough you're going to
start being like what the [ __ ] like we
should unionize this is crazy
boom much harder we're hiring a
bajillion people yeah we just rotated
through another goodyear bajillion
exactly much harder to unionize when you
can't express solidarity with your
fellow uh assembly line and workers in
the distribution facility because you
don't know who the [ __ ] they are because
you know everyone else got fired
um in june of this year uh it was
reported that they have an annual
turnover rate of warehouse employees of
a hundred and fifty percent
meaning
every week about three percent of their
total workforce is quitting or being
fired wait how can you have a hundred
fifty percent because more people
more people are fired per year
at an amazon warehouse than there even
are total employees working at the
warehouse meaning they're downsizing too
yeah they're downsizing so yeah here's
the thing about that
15 an hour
shouts out to bernie sanders for
bullying jeff bezos into doing that is
now a marketing position for amazon i
see it all the time i get ads from
amazon distribution facilities i don't
know why the [ __ ] they're wasting their
time and money on me but whatever um and
it's 15 an hour flat that's their
minimum wage right for the distribution
facilities
and that is if you live in a place like
bessemer alabama that's a really good
[ __ ] gig especially if you compare it
to the 725 you would otherwise get if
you're working in any other comparable
you know fast food industry type job
right
so
that's how they hook you
but
i tracked the bessemer alabama
unionization efforts closely
and what i found out was that
yeah it's higher
when you compare it to other jobs in the
fast food industry and whatnot
but it's lower
than other distribution facilities in
that same region why because there are
distribution facilities in that same
region that are unionized so the
unionized distribution facilities have
better benefits and on top of that
they're getting 22 dollars an hour at
the minimum so that's how they that's
how they get you they'll be like well 15
an hour sounds great you you start the
job and you're like this is back
breaking yeah ruling labor i mean i mean
i mean
warehouse work is
it's not really and i mean it can be
entry level but it's a specialized job
it's not easy
work
if i
were to
uh you know if i wasn't doing agitated
propaganda or if i was watching this
right now
and i truly wanted to uh create labor
momentum in this country i would salt in
amazon distribution facilities because
the reality is
salting is when you uh are you take a
job you get a job at a you
at a non-unionized place
as someone who is like a representative
of the uh of the union
uh that you know you go and you take a
job and you start you know prodding
people like hey maybe you should [ __ ]
unionize right this is [ __ ] up this is
that's a
secret agent jesus would kill you if you
did that probably i think he i think he
would launch your body into space
probably yeah blue origin baby blue
origins
baby yeah when you're in space nobody
finds you yeah they put you right at the
tip of that [ __ ] dick right through
your body out like a [ __ ] [ __ ] load
yeah so um and the reason why i say that
though is because
right now
um we are once again seeing how much
power uh
people that work on the supply chain on
the logistics side on the delivery sides
and also on the distribution side have
but they are super disorganized but in
areas where they are organized like
dude they could literally shut the
economy down because
um we we are not a productive labor
force unfortunately anymore
manufacturing has been uh outsourced uh
uh to to you know china and even though
now china's uh economic situation has
improved so now they are also double
outsourcing it to like other places you
know bangladesh and whatnot
um but
because of that
we can't really do like a general strike
or anything like that and completely
shut down uh
manufacturing but there's always going
to be a need for delivery
so
unions in the longshoreman side the
stevedores and and
truck drivers and people that work in
distribution facilities
they're always going to be necessary
labor because even if you buy the
package you have to get it right you
have to have it delivered to you you
have to have that
taken off the shipping container and
whatnot and that's precisely why like if
i were to uh try to reignite like labor
momentum class consciousness and whatnot
and show the rest of the working class
that like no you do have a profound
amount of power that is the one area
that is like definitely ripe for
for labor action even militancy um i do
think that like it could be militancy
labor militancy like uh strikes uh
pushing back making sure that scabs
can't get into the facilities and
whatnot i mean it's a it's it's really
it's a scary thing because you directly
put yourself
in contention with the federal
government at that point and
historically you people that have done
so have gone to jail eugene debs is a
famous example of this um
and uh you know cops will break through
that picket line and crush your skull to
bring in those gabs but
um you know it is it is one thing that
uh
unions are
the minute those uh
those daddy bezos delivery fees go up
the americans will turn on the unions
bezos can [ __ ]
he can make it happen he gets rid of
that free shipping on prime
crush the unions
um i think that you're you're you are
correct but that's why you would also
have to effectively communicate the
desires appropriately and show the world
like the human side of it
no way i i agree with you i'm just
saying that in the end it doesn't matter
because
if they were to accept
if they are able to
effectively
push back
then uh it's more of a war of attrition
at that point it doesn't matter if the
[ __ ] media is like you guys are
pieces of [ __ ]
uh because
every single moment that you are uh
engaging it does matter in a way because
people people scabbing out of uh
a
false sense of uh justice or like [ __ ]
y'all i'm going in there because it
working for jeff bezos is the right
thing to do to make sure free shipping
stays free yeah i mean you you see it in
like the the
non-artificial the like very legitimate
uh supply shortage of labor right now
there's a tight labor market in in
places like canada there's like old
restaurant owners that are literally
working for free at other restaurants
because they're like god forbid we
increase wages and make sure that
there's like actual people that come in
and work at the restaurants themselves
but instead they're like we'll just do
it for free but you can't do that
forever you know what i mean
that's why i said it's a war of
attrition
and also the teamsters and stuff i mean
teamsters are so [ __ ] loaded like
they have incredible strike funds
uh so they could they could hold out for
a very long i hope i'm wrong by the way
you know
for some reason but daddy basil
shouldn't be paying people more but they
teamsters themselves also have internal
struggle currently uh they're trying to
restructure away from
the old
you know
mafia adjacent governance uh so
you know they are also going through
their own internal politics at the
moment so
it's a complicated situation i'm just
simply saying that this is like a this
is like a good
area well they have a lot of such a
crazy labor shortage too it's going to
be a lot harder to find scabs it's not
like people are you for work yup nobody
wants to work well until until the
government
until the chamber of commerce is like
we need to start [ __ ] using the
national guard to like literally force
people to go to work or use the national
guard itself but you see it all the time
like these are a lot of these jobs are
not super easy to fulfill especially
maybe a distribution facility is a
little bit uh you know
a little less um
uh a little easier to train and you know
uh and fulfill but
you see this example with the john deere
strikes that are currently going on
where they bring in scabs and people
just start dying yeah you bring a
[ __ ] yeah immediately the next
morning you got 911 911 calls like
because they're [ __ ] breaking the
[ __ ] they don't know how to they don't
know how you use like this heavy
machinery you mean they don't take care
of you
no
do you see that uh oh here here's one of
my favorite elected officials i've been
following his career since before he got
elected because i i don't know if you've
seen
his whole family came together to knock
on him yeah
and even before he got elected i was
like this guy must be a big piece of
[ __ ] for his whole [ __ ] family and he
has not let me down he is one of the
shittiest most psychotic freaks
in congress right now
uh just for reference here i don't know
how anybody wins office after this but
watch this doing anything to help rural
america paul's absolutely not working
for his district if they care about
health care they care about their
children's health
they would hold him to account if they
care about jobs
they would hold him to account
if he actually cared about people in
rural arizona
i bet he'd be fighting for social
security for better access to health
care i better he i bet he would be
researching what is the most insightful
water policy to help the environment of
arizona sustain itself
and be successful
he's not listening to you and he doesn't
have your interests at heart my name is
tim gosar david gosar grace gosar joan
gosar gaston gosar jennifer gosar paul
gosar's my brother my brother and i
endorse dr grill dr bill wholeheartedly
endorsed dr david brill for congress
he's no longer david
he got destroyed by the ghost star his
whole family came together and said [ __ ]
this guy we hate him he sucks and he's
still one man
yup
yeah we actually called it getting
go-sarted when you get totally [ __ ] by
by your family members but i get it at
first i was like wow how could they do
this to him but i get it now
yeah i mean look
it my man
is out there doing the most of the
people arizona i'm just like looking
through his bills right now of like what
he is uh look at this
70 landslide yeah he just [ __ ]
crushed it people arizona and district
four were like this is our guy
this is our guy
i'm gonna like this guy yeah the whole
family hates him but uh which by the way
that's a very marketable position
because a lot of conservatives
unironically have that exact same
problem yeah it's like oh yeah my family
hates me too because i'm a truth teller
just like paul gosar
well gosar is even more he's like
straight like q and on conspiracy theory
oh yeah he was uh
it's been speculated that he had stuff
to do with the january 6th he's one of
the congressmen that's understood he has
fundraised uh i believe for uh a nazi
whose name i will not say um i don't
even want to give him clout but like
he's he's appeared on events uh with
like actual [ __ ] white nationalists
and [ __ ] yeah he he's like he's the base
he's the base like chad griper
nationalist like it's like these these
[ __ ] dildos on the internet like
these [ __ ]
moronic like uh
neck bearded in-cell losers he's just a
weird facebook boomer and they think
he's based because he's openly racist
yeah and it's like yeah first of all
did it better okay like yeah you already
had steve king dawg okay you had one of
those and they didn't consider him based
because he didn't know he didn't have a
[ __ ] intern that was like producing
anime um you know music videos for him
but
but also like
at the end like if you're one of these
like 12 [ __ ] weirdos on the internet
these like turbo cucks who think like my
representative is gonna do based
nationalism okay it's gonna be sick
white ethno state like if you're one of
those guys like first of all those guys
don't even [ __ ] vote so it doesn't
matter um because they can't leave their
house they all have agoraphobia but
secondly bracelets i thought you were
gonna say yeah well that too
but uh secondly like if you're one of
those [ __ ] weirdos like wait you
think paul gosar is gonna [ __ ] do the
fourth reich he's not gonna do it he's
not gonna do [ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ]
sponsor like a couple wildlife
protection bills okay he's gonna [ __ ]
name a couple post offices and then in
the end he's gonna be like uh i don't
know deregulate uh methane uh uh
emissions production so that like what
like [ __ ] you can frack better yeah
and pollute the planet better and he
makes he makes off and and tax cuts for
corporations so you're not you don't
have like the the chad white nationalist
based guy that you just think liberal
tears we'd love that but here here's
what he tweeted out he actually erased
the door i think twitter erased it for
inciting violence maybe ugh coward
this is the attack on titan actually i
take it back twitter is awesome for
deleting anime
and i say this is an anime fan
representative paul gosar is
the freedom fighting
by the way this edit is horrible oh yeah
so here he
is at the capitol
it's just a still photo uh these are
immigrants
yeah we want to kill apparently blood
splatters blood splatters on immigrants
breaking dangerous crossings
bro what the [ __ ]
and then the
the brave men and women of the customs
and border patrol hold the [ __ ] phone
immigrants with blood splatters over
them this is
psychotic yeah
yeah
it is the thing is that like
it doesn't matter if this anime video
gets made or not like the joe biden
administration is the one that's
ultimately
still doing the very same [ __ ] that the
trump administration did in the exact
same ways by the way we just don't get a
lot of coverage on the media because the
media does not give a [ __ ] about
immigrants
just messaging wise though this is a bad
this is not a good
uh image no no
i don't want vigilantes going and
killing immigrants which is kind of what
well we got the cpp doing it anyway so
here they are this is our glorious uh
border patrol
standing in attention heroes
murderer what was so ironic about attack
on titan is that they're walled in
trying to get out
i don't know i i mean i watched it the
the analogy is weird but okay maybe they
didn't think about it too much some
people say that it's like uh fascist
some people say it's like actually
leftist
um it does get spicier it does get
really funny in a second let's keep
going
uh this is
a titan
you got violence
uh oh
horseback left
on horseback
okay and then you have like what is what
and then you [ __ ]
no
you know marjorie titan green is a
[ __ ] titan she definitely is some of
those homies spoiler alert but like some
of those homies are titans so i think
that's what he's seen
oh man
did you not know that dan no i'm just
kidding yeah okay yeah i mean yeah
i i haven't watched the fourth season
yesterday and i didn't know four seasons
i'm trying to just get a close look at
this because it happened so fast that's
disturbing that is so disturbing how it
just shows that close-up of her face so
fast yeah
yeah she's definitely a titan like she's
like
oh my god aoc but they say like aoc is
the actual titan and once again so aoc
is a titan and they're x they're killing
her yeah
yeah
it's awesome
why do white nationalists love anime
like all these did you have you noticed
that like all these [ __ ] nazis online
do you want to know that
well because they they sent the japanese
who are like the super wraith race
ethnos that but also they're so [ __ ]
stupid that they think that like
anime is devoid of like western liberal
pc culture that like the jews created in
the frankfurt school oh for real and
it's like
no it's because they [ __ ] love lolly
[ __ ] they're pedophiles
and
and i see this
like there's a lot of [ __ ] weird
pedophilia [ __ ] that happens in anime
yeah okay
they like that they think falsely that
the world's largest [ __ ] amirabu
population
which are the japanese who are
incredibly influenced by american
culture
are creating art that
is is somehow devoid of like uh you know
american culture for some reason it's
not even true
but they have no way of like analyzing
subtext or context or art in any
meaningful capacities that's why they
look at like
that's why they like homelander for
example when they watch the boys and
they're like oh homelander that's a
great guy he looks no
it's like dog he's the villain he's
definitely the you're he's you he's the
bad guy yeah yeah there anyway here we
go let's see
so they've killed aoc they've killing
the immigrants they're killing joe biden
that's gosar killing joe biden
why didn't they show that cowards they
should have shown it like the cutting
cutting the neck of joe biden the titan
post out
and oh god they're dropping and on
parachutes to kill immigrants seems over
the top or are they saying that the
immigrants are parachuting in
i'm confused by that no that's no
they're saying they're they're dropping
it yeah they're dropping in the kill oh
so what a legend we love him don't we
yeah my take on this is that like
i mean aoc tweeted about this and like
there are very real threats to her
safety obviously yeah but like this
isn't
like i just well you know what she goes
she she makes a good point she i think
she said
a creepy member i work with who
fundraises for neo-nazi groups shared a
fantasy video of him killing me and
he'll face no consequences because gop
leaders cheer him on
with excuses yeah i mean look i i i
don't think he's actually threatening
her life but this kind of [ __ ] is
not helpful for her so i mean and sure
dude people actually want to kill her
like there's no 100 dude people want to
kill me so like yeah people want to kill
me
like
um i i understand why she would complain
i mean it's it's weird you what if like
[ __ ] uh
what no it's weird i agree with no they
did that they did that for donald trump
remember like people [ __ ] lost their
minds when uh what's her face
kathy griffin was like
here is a simulated donald trump murder
uh video i thought hers was pretty
tasteless too but obviously yeah but
they were like oh my god like what the
[ __ ] like yeah what if aaron sees this
like
it's like a dude no it's just i
personally think that this is like
this is nothing like you should just
clown on it and i think like
uh i think this is one of those things
where you're like dude you are such a
[ __ ] weirdo loser to like put this
together if any if go star ever
mentioned me i would just show that clip
of his whole family denouncing him in an
ad for one of his opponents i didn't
care that makes him more powerful these
guys have these guys have humiliation
fetishes like
you know he's like he's got his nipple
clamps
probably stomps his [ __ ] real hard with
a stiletto end yeah
yeah there's just like he's gonna get
off on that he's like yeah my family
hates me huh so hot well how much time
we got down because our main story is
coming up big bird is a communist yeah
uh not very much so we'll just have to
slam through it uh relatively quickly
all right we have one more here we'll
set up this big bird as a communist uh
as you guys know sesame street has been
doing propaganda
for decades they are slowly assimilating
this greater graphics so far this great
capitalist commercie
into a uh [ __ ] communist
socialist
uh dystopian [ __ ]
why is that
um
well let me show you the tweet that set
the whole thing off
big bird went on to twitter and tweeted
the following
big bird the fictional character from
sesame street i got the kova 19 vaccine
today my wing is feeling a little sore
but it'll give my body an extra
protective boost that keeps me and
others healthy
that's right so we found out that's it
you know how he was dressed when he uh
tweeted that
[Laughter]
oh well that makes sense yeah oh that
makes sense that's why they're all
turned
big expose the hassan obvi head that
that makes sense okay oh i didn't see
that photo before yeah
yeah cam actually if you could re-edit
that and shrink his head a little bit
oh actually yeah i do want to see that
yeah i actually do want to see that yeah
i have a perfectly sized head okay these
are all lies
look how normal it looks with the rest
of my body okay
lens distortion
well yeah we have a special lens to
enlarge your head size and keep your
body yeah
anyways it's a three garillion dollar
studio this is what the most of the
budget goes through that's making my
head look normal size
we do a whole post graphic editing we
have a whole we have like a 10 man
special effects team just
grinding out that's where the five
percent went
yeah so
zach you love that chuck you never get
tired of that
love you for that yeah so this is the
culture war of the week is that sesame
street is communist because big bird
says he got the vaccine shot and uh he's
fine now why would big bird tweet out um
this propaganda i got the covet vaccine
today my wing is feeling a little sore
but it'll give my body extra protection
well sesame street is a is a show for
kids
and it seems to me that you know
you should not be advertising public
safety measures to kids right i agree
that's communism i mean they should not
be um let's see i have a lot i used to
have a lot of anxiety over needles so
let's see big bird is trying to con uh
console and encourage and make kids feel
better and comfortable about uh uncomfy
things they might have to do
that's communism somehow
um
and he's talking directly the kids with
challenges that they might have they're
probably afraid of covet 19 they might
be afraid of catching kova 19 and
killing their family um so you know this
seems right up uh big bird's alley but
um apparently this is communism let me
play some clubs here yeah communism is
when you have a mass vaccination
campaign obviously everybody knows this
just
everything that people don't everything
that conservatives have decided is not
uh good is is communism government
propaganda for five-year-olds ted cruz
it's just big bird trying to [ __ ]
make kids feel better about getting
shots you absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] stain of
a vile human being you know you know
he's vaccinating his children yeah of
course you know that's like
they're they're also like minecraft
stands i know for a fact so
these kids his kids like
uh probably are aware that like
their father is a [ __ ] villain like
also government propaganda it's like bro
last i checked you work for the
government yeah
yeah well that's the conservative
there's the conservative rhetoric
harvard graduate ted cruz by the way
didn't go to harvard i think also i
think he's harvard wendy rogers from
arizona that's where all the great
grades come big bird is a communist i
don't understand the whole com this is
the thread you guys will see how is um
consoling children's about the fear of
getting uh a shot communistic that i
don't get i don't get it that's what
that's what was written in das capital
most people don't read it but like it's
really important oh sorry the critique
of the go with the program actually
where uh where
karl marx famously wrote you know shots
mass inoculation for the working class
for the proletariat is is
a profoundly important value
it's the most important thing yeah
uh sanjay gupta he's a doctor that works
on cnn yeah who's basically like uh
pushing drugs in parentheses vaccine the
kids on sesame street is now the
cringey's most shameful thing i've ever
seen why are they lying to us it's like
you've seen psycho sick [ __ ] freak
show dude this is not the most shameful
thing you've ever seen let's be real you
have no shame they're not pushing drugs
on kids they all have been vaccinated
like stop this insanity you sick
freak [ __ ]
no it's awesome fictional character
played by man in bird suit giving
medical advice says sebastian gorka
uh who you know is uh
is also kind of a fictional character
played by a man
a lizard in a human suit
who is this person i have no idea who
the [ __ ] laverne spicer is who's laverne
spicer
let's look it up and ju sebastian gordon
the politician apparently well porka was
a adviser to trump and oh no no i know
who gorka is of course goku
she is a
politician
from she ran for the election of the
united states uh house
uh she's
sitted right now to represent florida's
24th congressional district and she lost
in the general election all right so
that's it
there's all she yeah there's all she
who's the [ __ ] doctor johnny
uh a doctor obviously i so
you can't lie on the internet dan don't
don't [ __ ] don't because i saw that
and i immediately had the same thought
of like yeah right this guy's a doctor i
looked it up but you know what he is
communist he's a chiropractor
uh yeah the only honest doctor
by the way he goes the ones trolling
aaron rodgers a super bowl mvp athlete
are the same ones taking medical advice
from burglary you mean this name [ __ ]
who's taking medical advice from joe
rogan yeah
yeah also you're a [ __ ] chiropractor
shut the [ __ ] up yeah chiropractors piss
me off dude i don't know what you guys
talking about they are the real doctors
everyone else is fake i only get my
medical advice from from chiropractors i
get my medical advice from the guy who's
like famous on take talk for like
snapping people's necks
you know i love tick-tock chiropractors
there's this one guy been following i
think they're in russia they take a
mallet they put a stick and they
slam their back with a mouth it's the
most awesome [ __ ] up [ __ ] i've ever
seen if one of you guys can pull that up
i like it
yeah so those are the tweets um here is
uh on newsmax of course they did a
little nice little piece there
uh newsmax host uh continues his war on
the muppets
in fact he goes listen i was right
[ __ ] back even in 2011 i called
kermit that cute little green monster
commie just this week so this guy get
fired from fox news for dick pics or
something for sexual harassment
what's his name
i'll look into it right now
didn't he write like a manifesto about
raping your wife no
okay
eric bowling yeah yeah yeah wait hold on
i'm almost certain that i basically
remember that story i did not connect it
to this guy though yeah yeah sex
pictures they they fired him at fox news
over sex pictures
uh which is of course like if you get
fired from fox news for doing sexual
harassment it's like really our tv you
must have been devious okay
because like that's kind of how you get
promoted they're like oh wow eric you
did a really good job the numbers this
month eric yeah
you're uh we're looking at your
quarterly dick pic report and uh
honestly you haven't been sexually
harassing one thing i can guarantee is
nobody wants to see your dick bro just
stop yeah nobody i kind of want to see
his dick
i would like to
like i consent to seeing her if you're
watching uh
we'll get you a song's number i i want
to know it's probably gross yeah
definitely curiosity morbid curiosity so
anyway uh newsmax is basically the
gutter of fox news and here is the piece
they did on baby big bird from sesame
street indoctrinating our five-year-olds
yes
and i've scheduled an appointment for my
grandson we're leaving in a few minutes
now i just need to get one last thing
before we go to your appointment big
bird okay i'll be right back all right
wait there's like a granny bird what i
have here is what we needed for your
teddy bear
five-year-old
get vaccinated yes it's time to go big
bird all right anyway then the giant
pigeon took to twitter to announce
to everyone how it felt about getting
the shot not the first time these little
felt communists have tried to infect the
minds of our youngest and most
vulnerable children
decade ago way back in 2011 i called out
kermit that cute little green monster
commie
the green monster comedy dude he's like
he's a hipster he's like i was doing
about worse
we were poor we were dead broke in fact
that my parents would see someone
wealthy driving by be like see that guy
he started a business he worked hard you
can be like that someday not pointing
the finger at text rich man and saying
he's a bad guy
well here's what happened the muppets
were blaming the oil bearing for closing
down
like literally weird [ __ ] they play
the rock there dude
totally irrelevant oh that's cute you
little oppressive muppets they didn't
even try to hide their disdain for an
impressive muppet by naming the guy
texts richmond
but i took them to task what a guy
he took him to tat yeah so um back then
in 2011 he was allegedly uh also uh you
know
he was he was uh allegedly coercing um
into sexual relationships female
commentators for guest spots on his show
i guarantee he didn't learn that from
the muppets no i don't think the muppets
[ __ ]
yeah
kermit is just you know smashing miss
piggy hermit smash oh yeah he claps
those cheeks for sure clapping those
cheeks
uh that's why he was mad did you know i
want to clap miss piggy's cheeks do you
know ben shapiro wrote a book about uh
sesame street being communism
he is a child brained person so that's
not surprising ben shapiro has been on
the sesame street communism beat for a
while he wrote a book in 2011 called
prime time propaganda about leftist
propaganda
in the media the tv series friends
undermines family values he said sesame
street taught ethnic minorities about
civil disobedience
what yeah
i did not know that i love that
brilliant they're so creative with their
like
i mean that's just like they probably
did a segment about how great like
martin luther king jr is yeah like if
you remove yourself for a brief moment
and like look at it from a top down
point of view like that's just
schizophrenic like no disrespect to
people who are schizophrenic like you
know i hope you're getting the help you
need but like
that is just like
that's like a that's a crazy thing to
think sesame street taught ethnic
minorities about civil disobedience
yeah it's true that's what ben shapiro
wrote that's right count dracula i mean
that's just that's like
that's like basically close to like
slavery uh values yeah like don't teach
those blacks how to protest safe uh i
wanna know how to protest uh peacefully
i to know what like the extent of like i
wish i knew what the problem was like
what what were they doing here i have
more info sesame street tried to tackle
divorce tackle peaceful conflict
resolution in the aftermath of 9 11 and
had gay actors neil patrick harris on
the show playing the subtly named fairy
shoe person right shapiro and since 95
percent of americans have watched the
show by the time to three years old well
the levels of brainwashing must be
astronomical he wrote
that's insane so one of his criticism is
that a gay person was on the show as
well
that is just like
i just oh god that's that's so wild dude
it's so wild i don't know i i don't know
what to say about that other than like
like that's
if that is your concern if that's your
like big concern the then i don't know
what to tell you like that is not
salvageable at all no and again this is
why it's so dis that's why it's so
concerning because ben shapiro again
titan of the right bro it's literally
the right dude this is the same energy
as being like
you know all the all the child's books
all the children's books that like uh
teach the
okay i hear i'll i'll do it right now
you know this is a ben shapiro this is
bench bureau rhetoric are you ready for
this it's like saying
um in a lot of our schools they're
teaching that uh they're teaching this
new morally irresponsible
idea that
guess what folks sharing is caring
that's right communism one of the one of
the main tenets of orthodox marxist
principles is sharing his character when
in fact it's actually what should be
taught in our schools is uh the
hijacking understand the hayek
understanding of the [ __ ] you know
and right
greed is good and that you need to look
after your self-interest sharing is for
beta communist who uh
sharing is literally going to be the
downfall of society it's just it's so
it's so insane like well yeah we need to
teach our children that you shouldn't
share
yeah because he goes uh he's sesame
street is teaching kids about divorce
which is an unfortunate truth of society
and it's very traumatic for kids that's
why it's on sesame street it's for the
kids my dude it's a beautiful thing
they're trying to teach kids they're
trying to comfort and teach kids who
don't have other resources like what the
[ __ ] could possibly be wrong with that
you callous evil satanic [ __ ] freak
of nature yeah like how dare we try to
console kids going through a traumatic
divorce tackling peaceful conflict
resolution and the aftermath of 9 11.
god forbid they teach us peaceful
conflict resolution that's communism
that's right
it's communism peaceful conflict
resolution
also communism is a violent ideology
yeah
yeah of course and then
this one's just openly like i hate gay
people and had gay actor neil patrick
harris on the show playing uh the fairy
shoe person so that's a big problem
i'm inside your walls ben yeah seriously
ben shapiro is actually just he's like
mentally ill he's like i don't know what
to say
yeah it's like i learned about peaceful
conflict resolution by watching sesame
street and also that sharing is a good
value and now i'm a communist
well the truth is oh here's the updated
one uh sorry to do this to you but if
you look on the tv screen there oh god
damn yeah oh wait i'm sorry oh this is
still the wrong one there we go oh my
okay dude
oh jesus christ actually um
[Applause]
it's actually ironic because big bird
has been helping kids
be comfortable with vaccinating since
the beginning
it's kind of a terrifying image if i saw
that i'd be like i'm not getting [ __ ]
vaccinated
that is very scary i agree but this i'm
five years old i'm like [ __ ] that dude
whatever that is i don't want it big
bird sesame street child immunization
campaign yeah because you know
yeah they've been commenting from the
jump this is further exposed once again
in 1972 big bird gets uh vaccinated so i
love how they're turning it's like oh my
god big bird is all of a sudden getting
involved in politics
this is from 1972. something's going on
down at the store
that's
i wonder what's
it's kind of funny i mean it's strange i
mean it's well there's all kinds of
people and they're all in a line and
they don't look like they're buying
candy and there's a sign that says
don't wait
vaccinate you don't say
terrifying
and yes there goes a boy with a balloon
coming out of the store hey what's going
on here nazi death camp yeah this is
literally you should have put a trigger
warning before this sorry i'm i'm so
triggered so that's that's one thing i
want to point out before we before we
end this is like don't you find it funny
that so many of these people that were
like
liberals are so sensitive
like oh they get triggered by the most
innocuous [ __ ] like
now they literally do the exact same
well they haven't really stopped they
were doing it back yeah too
and it's the exact same [ __ ] where
they're like frothing out of the mouth
big bird big bird telling kids that like
you should get vaccinated so you don't
have like [ __ ] measles yeah i mean
they have always been the most fragile
offendable people
even ever since the social justice
warrior craze that you know they are the
most fresh they are snowflakes
yeah but that's just they have the best
marketing though because it's always
like whatever i am you are and i
convince everyone of that yeah that's
why people um assume that like the left
is so censorious
meanwhile like 80 of the books that are
banned in in uh colleges and in high
schools greg abbott actually recently
said we don't we can't have pornographic
materials in our public schools what was
the pornographic material lgbt books
wow yeah like that and 80 of the books
that are canceled or or uh that are not
allowed for kids to be kids to read are
literally
uh backed by right-wing cause texas is
literally becoming um
what's that one hulu show
the [ __ ] oh hand manning's tail yeah
it's literally the handmaiden style it's
the new the new state of gilead
well they're because they're desperate
they see that like with an influx of
immigration and also uh with uh
with like a lot of people coming from
out of state into like places like
austin and whatnot texas is demographic
they want to follow everything and they
they want to try to like mobilize as
many right-wing psychos in the state as
they possibly can but that's what you
know progress is inevitable everything's
gonna
progress yeah unless you do fascism like
literally that's what i understand about
the whole conservative
regressive movement it's like you will
lose you will always lose you are wrong
you are
in the way of progress progress is
always the way it always has been since
the [ __ ]
inception of you know humanity um
i don't understand how you can even be
part of a regressive movement it
literally makes no sense well
it's all about like i said marketing
yourself as like doing something first
creating a problem like creating a
demand for something
and then simultaneously like looking
like a champion of that cause when the
overwhelming majority of americans don't
even give a [ __ ] or are in opposition to
those like morally bankrupt values
but what matters is
on the one hand you're stopping people
from going out to vote making as
difficult as possible you know uh you
know it's not a national holiday you got
all these like restrictions
that's deliberate that's by design yeah
you can stop the working class from
voting yeah and then
uh and simultaneously trying to activate
the most deranged base of voters
evangelical white evangelical
protestants uh and and the like to go
out and actually vote yeah they have my
game
that's how they win but yeah and then
and then they ultimately end up winning
and the other side needs to effectively
communicate year round in the same way
that republicans do
their values and then actually follow
through on said values but they don't do
that
can't believe big bird was caught
yeah oh omar no
people in nature before prophets
communist party so they were right we
got to cut the whole segment now guys
yep he is no he is a communist right
yeah exactly no big bird famously he's
like we we must seize the means of uh
production that's what you the sesame
street is has a communal aspect to it
that is very concerning yeah communism
you know they're all friendly with one
another instead of uh i've seen them in
experience
you know i've seen them having a
peaceful conflict resolution and dracula
teaching kids about math which is also
communist although there was one episode
where elmo dropped the [ __ ] uh drone
strike on big bird's house that was sick
yeah yeah
finally that was the kind of conflict
resolution i like to see yeah well
that's that's bad only when barack obama
does it but when donald trump does it
it's very good based elmo yeah all right
we have to wrap it up we're out of time
thank you everybody thank you son
welcome back yeah it's good to be back
you want to tease what we have in mind
for uh next week's uh episode we were
discussing ethan oh i don't know if i
told you about this idea no we want to
do a special episode next week because
it's the last app before thanksgiving
where we can do like faux debates to to
cue everyone up with the talking points
to own their conservative families on
thanksgiving dinner ooh love that sounds
fun right yeah yeah i i yeah i do that
uh already as i'm totally oh you do so
yeah so
um we got a lot to look for today uh
next week owning your family your
conservative psycho family members on
thanksgiving we will arm you to the
teeth for
for peaceful conflict resolution or not
let's just go full out violence
thanksgiving dinner baby
that's right this is the
generation patriots signing out
[Music]